what does it mean to have a pre disease
if you have slightly elevated blood
pressure does that mean that your pre
stroke or maybe in a sense we're all pre
death in 2001 the American Diabetes
Association began to call a slightly
elevated blood sugar level pre-diabetes
by 2005 the Centers for Disease Control
adopted a DEA standards and 41 million
people were estimated to be pre-diabetic
in comparison to 21 million diabetics in
the u.s. in 2010 the 88 broadened its
definition of the glycemic level that
would constitute free diabetes when
adopted by the CDC tens of millions more
people were swept into the definition
today 84 million Americans one in three
adults are considered pre-diabetic
meanwhile the number of diabetics in the
country is significantly lower 30
million people the majority of people
who are at the lower range of what the a
DA calls pre-diabetes never progressed
to diabetes this has been shown in many
studies pre-diabetes causes no symptoms
or complications and some international
organizations disavow the label one of
the problems that organizations like the
World Health Organization have with the
way in which pre-diabetes is defined and
managed in the United States and
elsewhere is that the subtext of all of
these prevention programs are that
people are essentially fat and lazy and
if they can only be more responsible eat
better exercise more they could solve
their problem all the programs are based
on individual clinical solutions to what
is really a broad socially driven
economically driven problem in our
society
one study done several decades ago
looked at people who were in low-income
housing and broke them into three groups
a control that received nothing another
group that received a little assistance
in finding new housing and a third that
got vouchers and assistance to relocate
to better housing after 20 years the
people who got the most help had the
least diabetes and obesity despite not
receiving nutrition and exercise
counseling or drugs no one in this
debate disputes that healthful
lifestyles exercise eating well eating
the right foods is vitally important for
everyone but it stands to reason that
more money going into the socio-economic
aspects of the problem could also be
important in solving the problem funding
is readily available to research
pharmacological solutions the incentives
to build drugs that are targeted to
pre-diabetes are great and so far the
Food and Drug Administration has never
approved any drugs specifically to treat
pre-diabetes so the drug makers are a
little bit hamstrung but there are drugs
used for diabetes or obesity that are
prescribed to patients off-label for
pre-diabetes although some side effects
from these drugs are relatively benign
others can be life-threatening
these side-effects are so serious that
many people have asked the question does
it make sense to even think about using
these drugs that could have
life-threatening consequences to treat
something that is a pre disease in 2014
the ATA estimated that 44 billion
dollars were spent on pre diabetic care
this is where it starts to get sticky
the profit motive the motivations for
using drugs it enters a murky area where
some of the people making the advice
also have financial conflicts with the
people who would profit from that trend
towards the use of drugs this so-called
disease has spawned a gigantic industry
of everything from glucose testing
monitors to herbal remedies that are
hocked online to naive patients since
the definition of pre-diabetes
was made and adopted by the CDC the
prevention budget that they have has
risen dramatically it's clear that this
has shifted the priorities of the agency
towards diabetes prevention while some
profit from the designation of
pre-diabetes patients are left to
grapple with the consequences of an
ambiguous diagnosis such as higher
health care costs and lesser health
insurance options it creates a lot of
anxiety in people who have been
diagnosed with pre-diabetes and
especially people who have limited
abilities to respond to that diagnosis
in an effective way because of their
genetics or because of their social
environment that they live in if you
have pre-diabetes designation
particularly if you're prescribed a drug
for it then that's a red flag for life
insurers and you may get an unfavorable
insurance rate so these aren't concrete
ways that people's lives could be
diminished
and this is not to say you should never
test people's blood sugar you should
never alert people to the importance of
diet and exercise the question is
whether you should institutionalize this
very broad range including a very mild
elevation of blood sugar as this
terrible problem of walking towards the
cliff and runaway train that could harm
people in these disastrous ways and that
have institutional effects downstream
that cost money to solve and create
anxiety for patients
[Music]
you
[Music]